E aí
[Música]
oi oi oi pessoal boa tarde obrigado pelo
convite e hoje eu vim aqui falar sobre
um tema que para mim é super importante
que a questão da Maternidade inclusive
se vocês ouvirem uma criança por aí é
porque o Antônio tá aqui presente desde
que ele nasceu ele sempre me acompanhou
nos eventos nos Octopus nos cursos que
eu gostaria de fazer e teve um episódio
específico onde eu entrar em contato com
o pessoal para saber se eu podia levar
ele no curso e me falaram que não podia
que ele acabar incomodando que não cabia
dentro daquele evento e na época isso
causou um incômodo assim porque que ele
não cabe naquele lugar e eu comecei a
pensar sobre como que as mulheres lidam
com essa parte profissional como é que
ela se colocam nesse lugar da carreira
como lidar né com todos esses papéis e
daí eu fui pesquisar foi entender um
pouco mais sobre esse universo até
porque ele começou a me do é essa
questão né E hoje se a gente observar a
maternidade ela tá ligada intimamente a
igualdade de
É porque tem uma pesquisa de um
professor de princeton da Universidade
de princeton que ele fala que a
possibilidade da mulher ser mãe já é um
fator que faz ter diferenciação de
salário eu não quer dizer nem que a
mulher seja né só a possibilidade de ser
e isso me incomodou bastante o último o
último fórum econômico Mundial ele
divulgou que o Brasil tá no penúltimo
lugar entre as Américas de igualdade
salarial a gente só perde para o Chile e
se a gente continuar com essa questão do
direito das mulheres como a gente tem
caminhado agora provavelmente somente
2095 que a gente vai chegar até uma
igualdade de gênero e aí eu fiquei
pensando fazendo isso pra essa reflexão
brasileira né hoje a recentemente né fiz
ela publicou um estudo falando que
cinquenta por cento das mulheres elas
são demitidas em até dois anos após
retornar ao mercado de trabalho e a
crescer fez uma pesquisa e 95
me falaram que tem dificuldade de lidar
com essa questão do profissional e da
Maternidade e é muitas vezes quando elas
não se sentem a braçadas dentro desse
mercado elas procuram empreendedorismo
hoje 34 por cento das empresas que são
abertas no Brasil são abertas por
mulheres segundo o SEBRAE EA rede mulher
empreendedora fez uma pesquisa 75 por
cento dessas mulheres são motivadas após
a maternidade não há problema algum das
mulheres serem empreendedores mas que
isso não seja o único caminho que elas
tenham que seguir só porque elas não
conseguem se enquadrar nesse mercado que
tá posto na forma como a gente tem a
nossa relação com o mercado de trabalho
como trabalho e aí a tecnologia que é o
tema né como que a tecnologia pode
transformar que é o tema desse ted's
aqui pode ser uma janela para a gente
poder pensar sobre outras alternativas
principalmente o mercado de tecnologia
da informação e aí é que eu queria
deixar uma observação que eu tenho
consciência do meu lugar de Privilégio
de uma mulher
o trabalho na área de tecnologia se a
gente fizer e o recorte para questões
sociais ou questões econômicas ou até
mesmo outros nichos de mercado eu sei
que é muito mais difícil é exceção dessa
mulher dentro do mercado de trabalho
após ser mãe mas eu vejo que talvez a
área de tecnologia possa mostrar esses
caminhos e fazendo essa transformação um
pouco a pouco uma construção coletiva
mesmo então é que eu queria trazer
alguns exemplos de coisas que estão
sendo feitas que estão boas e que a
gente poderia se inspirar e trazer para
o nosso dia a dia porque enxergar outra
mulher nesse lugar de liderança de que
consegue é muito importante a
representatividade importa muito quando
a gente vê uma se ou de uma empresa de
tecnologia grávida ser capa de uma
grande revista de negócios faz você se
enxergar naquela possibilidade de lugar
ou quando você ver uma pessoa por
exemplo você contratada com 9 meses de
gestação e tá tudo bem A empresa Está
celebrando isso também é muito
e que te faça essa possibilidade de que
você pode chegar nesse lugar e aí é que
eu queria levantar uma reflexão porque é
muito bom por um lado porque a gente tem
uma discussão enquanto sociedade a gente
fala sobre o assunto e aí isso promove
novas possibilidades promove novas
ideias Mas você também tem um problema
se isso de estou há muito se tornam
viral é porque não tá sendo praticado no
dia a dia então a gente tem que
equilibrar essa balança também ver o que
que tá sendo feito de prática O que que
a gente tá conseguindo colocar em ação e
casando essas duas coisas mas eu e eu
vou falar do mercado que eu conheço de
onde eu trabalho tem iniciativas muito
legais por exemplo o Home Office ele foi
super acelerado pela com de Mia né
empresas que às vezes nunca vi imaginado
pensar na ideia do Home Office tiveram
que fazer Home Office do dia para a
noite mas viram ali uma possibilidade e
Home Office é super inclusive para as
mulheres que têm filhos porque você
consegue lidar melhor com um dia a dia
você consegue trabalhar
é a questão dos horários flexíveis para
poder ser mais inclusivo jornada
reduzida Inclusive a licença maternidade
e paternidade estendida teve uma empresa
que fez a licença-paternidade de seis
meses e aí tem um caso uma observação
curiosa porque a maior parte dos pais
não aderiram à licença-paternidade de
seis meses e eles foram questionar a
procurar saber porque que os pais não
queriam participar e eles se sentirão
como se a empresa fosse olhar para eles
e achar que eles não estavam dando
sangue que eles não tavam sabe se
entregando ali naquela oportunidade ele
se sentir desmerecidas com medo de
perder o posto de trabalho e isso é
muito interessante porque é o que as
mulheres vivem no dia a dia e às vezes a
gente não se preocupa com isso a maior
parte das mulheres quando engravida E aí
eu falo de mim também quando eu
engravidei por mais que na empresa onde
eu trabalhava tinha os programas eram
inclusive
Oi gente o medinho lá no fundo diz que
se aquele lugar ainda te cabe além de
discutir a maternidade é importante a
gente discutiu os programas esse eles
estão bem estão sendo bem aceitos pela
pelas empresas pelos funcionários eles
estão conseguindo perceber isso como o
valor também esse eles estão discutindo
isso internamente essa luta da
Maternidade Ela não é uma luta só das
mulheres ou só das mulheres que querem
ter filhos ela é uma luta social para
que a gente consiga alcançar essa
igualdade de gênero que é tão importante
os filhos precisam ser filhos no
currículo tanto dos Pais quanto das Mães
porque isso vai fazer um enorme
diferença lá na frente porque a geração
de hoje vai tomar outra percepção sobre
o trabalho sobre como se posicionar no
mercado porque não vai ver a mãe ou o
pai tratando eles como se fosse um
impeditivo de carreira isso é importante
E aí na outra ponta a gente tem
coletivos que promovem
uma das mulheres ferramentas para que
elas participem dos processos seletivos
a gente também tem Startup E aí vem um
pouco dessa tecnologia promovendo e se
mete entre as empresas que querem
contratar e as mães que estão no mercado
e querem voltar para o mercado de
trabalho é importante a tecnologia nesse
ponto tem políticas públicas sem
políticas públicas muitas mulheres não
conseguiriam voltar para o mercado de
trabalho ou permanecer é importante ter
as creches é importante ter as escolas
com os horários estendidos tem um
provérbio africano que fala que é
necessário uma aldeia para cuidar de uma
criança então não basta ter só as
empresas ter só o poder público é
preciso que a gente também incorpora
essa ideia né enquanto indivíduo cada um
de nós aqui pensando que que a gente
pode fazer E aí eu trouxe alguns
exemplos aqui para que a gente possa
refletir sobre isso e tornar-se uma
prática é muito importante a gente
pensar é muito importante esse espaço
para discutir
é realmente sim significativo se a gente
começar a praticar porque são coisas
pequenas ações ao longo do tempo que a
gente consegue fazer essa transformação
que a gente deseja Então se a gente
pensar nas nossas ações individuais o
que que nós poderíamos propor conversar
sobre o assunto porque aquelas pessoas
que não fazem parte do universo da
Maternidade e da paternidade desconhecem
Quais são as nossas dificuldades no dia
a dia no ambiente profissional propôs
conversas propõe o diálogo falar sobre
essas dificuldades levar as mães até as
oportunidades vocês indicarem mulheres
mães cobrados RH se para que tenha
cinquenta por cento de participação de
homens e de mulheres nos processos
seletivos para que isso seja mais
igualitário e aí uma outra coisa que eu
tenho super vivenciados no dia-a-dia a
empatia Por que você tá no Home Office
Antônio tá lá chorando jogou um
brinquedo no chão e aí aquela confusão e
às vezes as pessoas não tem tanta
empatia com a gente assim
e fala que tem mas na hora do vamos ver
daquela barulhada acaba perdendo empate
então quando é que a gente está
exercendo efetivamente a empatia com os
nossos colegas que tem filhos às vezes
aqueles pais que fazem horário super
alternativas para dar conta da jornada
do dia então é bom a gente exercitar
essa empatia um viés inconsciente Às
vezes a gente reproduz preconceitos
estruturais têm Às vezes tem nem
perceber então quando a gente fala eu já
ouvi algumas vezes né de outros relatos
de outras mulheres a Não vou dar não vai
dar conta porque tem filho a não vou
contratar porque vai sair mais cedo
porque precisa levar o filho para
consultar isso não é verdade ou não é
uma verdade totalmente absoluta a
possibilidades com essas questões de
programas dentro das empresas que isso
fique mais flexível Que caiba todo mundo
dentro dessa carreira profissional e o
último ponto que eu queria trazer aqui
que é a questão do trabalho doméstico
o último censo do IBGE apontou que as
mulheres têm o dobro de horas gastas
durante a semana do que os homens dentro
do trabalho doméstico então que você tá
fazendo no dia a dia para que a mulher
que mora com você sua mãe sua irmã sua
parceira uma colega para que ela tenha
tempo para dedicar à carreira
profissional tá sendo bem dividido esses
trabalhos domésticos as coisas estão
sendo bem pensadas Nesse quesito porque
a tendo tempo que as mulheres vão
conseguir também exercer workshops
exercer a possibilidade de participar de
cursos de aprimorar a sua carreira
profissional e aqui eu queria terminar
com uma frase que é uma frase da Thais
Vilarinho que ela fala que vamos lutar
todos os dias para que as mulheres não
precisam escolher entre a carreira EA
maternidade e para que os nossos meninos
eles possam além de ser bons
profissionais possam ser pais altamente
participativos eu espero que essa
reflexão Fi
eu sei que ela possa se transformar em
ação no dia-a-dia de cada um que está
assistindo essa palestra muito obrigada
tá